Congress is on the brink of a shutdown
literally tomorrow Nancy Pelosi won't
admit that because that would be
admitting the Democrats are shutting the
government down because Republicans
refuse to legalize people here illegally
she's claiming Democrats want to shut
the government down because the
Republican Party is trying to do
something repulsive
here's her explanation this is like
giving you a bowl of doggy Doo put a
cherry on top and call it a chocolate
sundae this is nothing well meanwhile
over at CNN Chris Cuomo says the
Republican Party is guilty of the
horrifying sin of vilifying people who
snuck into our country and are demanding
rights and money here he is you guys
have a pretty intentional effort to make
illegal immigrants as you call them
monsters you put out this DHS report
today that fictionalize is the risk of
terror that is represented by people who
come into this country illegally we
understand that that's against the law
we understand that it has to stop but
why make them all into villains mark
Stein is an author and columnist and an
actual thinker and he joins us tonight
so mark when people like the guy we just
showed put air quotes around the phrase
illegal immigrant does that mean are you
not allowed to admit that they're
immigrating illegally yeah I think he
doesn't recognize that category what's
what's interesting is that both he and
Nancy Pelosi and others on that side of
the aisle are getting ever more explicit
in their preference for illegal
immigrants called as he would say over
American citizens he said Chris Cuomo
went on to say that the real problem is
white supremacists in America they're
the real monsters not these nice
hard-working illegal immigrants and that
may be well and true I mean for the
purposes of argument let's just say he's
right it's irrelevant the white
supremacists are American citizen
the illegal immigrants are people who
shouldn't be here and every the the
organizing principle of nation-states is
that they're organized on behalf of
their citizens whether their citizens
are cheerleaders or or or white
supremacists or whatever you're stuck
with them
and this preference that Nancy Pelosi
and Chris Cuomo and increasing people
have for actually importing a class of
citizen that they prefer to the ones
they're stuck with is actually very
revealing but how can you lead a country
whose population you despise I mean
would you be a good parent if you hated
your kids would you be an effective
officer if you didn't care about the
safety of your men I mean doesn't that
kind of prima facie show that you're not
ready to lead if you don't love the
people you're leading no I mean you said
what about parents and kids every family
I think it was Malcolm Muggeridge
who said that friends are God's apology
for relatives in other words you pick
your your friends you're stuck with your
relatives that the Democrats are getting
very close to saying that foreigners are
God's apology for Americans Nancy Pelosi
has explicitly said that we should thank
the parents of these so-called dreamers
these daca people for bringing them here
illegally and in fact to go back to what
your Swedish guest was saying you know
whatever the economic benefits which are
minimal and are not evenly distributed
the cultural transformation which is
what's happening in Sweden other parts
of Europe and is what's happening in
Arizona too that's forever in Arizona a
majority of the grade school children
now are Hispanic
that means Arizona's future is as an
Hispanic society that means in effect
the border has moved north and the
cultural transformation outweighs any
economic benefits that that lady was
talking about it's at the very least
bouldering for people who grew up here
and that's real I don't think you have
to be animated by hate or anything to
say you
maybe I should have some say in what how
my country evolved mark thank you very
much
thanks a lot Tucker